die lakers liegen so salzig deswegen so
sein wobei cleggs geruch nutzen der
tägliche service erst geht's und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute wie ken allen situationen ihr sitz
in der bar oder im restaurant oder im
café und bestellt eine cola
dann fragt euch den fucking kellner geht
auch pepsi klar wurde dadurch so klar
selbstverständlich mal lieber mit
spielgeld und genau das thema tritt ist
heute wieder leute denn wir testen heute
real versus fake also quasi die
originalprodukte gegner nach mache und
gucken ob man blind der unterschied
erkennen kann wer das sind leute der
kameras magst du wird gleich vor die
kamera kommen und mit mir bringt die
produkte ausprobieren und ich will sagen
ich zeige euch kurz was ich geholt
fachleute mit prinzenrolle kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder von euch hat jeder
mal geflutet wahrscheinlich früher in
der schulzeit vor allem und fdp mit 46
prozent kakao einfärben und was ist
duellieren oder also ich wäre jetzt
schon klar abonnieren durchschnittlich
noch leute -modell es kann ja auch alle
haben wir auch alle kiloweise gefressen
wenn nicht aber so einfach wie
klassische nähert muss schocks da noch
weiter mit diesen krieg sind heute
leiter des kriegs muss ich gestehen
fräst sich heutzutage immer noch mal
wenn ich aus u bahnfahrer wollen sie da
wird sich so eine packung kekse für
seine drei stunden autobahnfahrt und
dann werden sie soweit 200 kann gegessen
und das stimmt natürlich nicht auf jeden
fall haben wir noch schoko keks beste
wahl ist es die beste wahl hätte das
würde um diese machen über den test
das beste wahl ist herrscht das recht
selbstständig deutsche darf auch nicht
fehlen orions diese aber lustigerweise
billiger als der fake hast du das schon
mal gehört
solltet ihr matschie und alsfeld haben
wir tortilla chips mit käse geschmack
und seine leute haben wir
selbstverständlich auch noch etwas
flüssiges und zwar cola light und
alsfeld haben wir afri cola okay wir
sind noch dabei ist oder wo clubbesitzer
gekauft es kann losgehen der kamera ist
die bezauberte hinter der kamera ist
lena leute und die wird uns jetzt einen
teller mit jeweils einem feld im
original reichen wir machen die augen zu
schauen wir das ganze video bergleute
wer am besten erkennen kann lasten fair
ist und was sagt man auch riechen
ok habe ich entschieden mich entschieden
ich sage das hier ist original und das
hier ist defekt und selbst das ist das
original aber durch gegenpunkte jetzt
kommen wir haben im stoxx leute machen
die augen zu
was ist schöner als die originale aber
die fakes und möchte mich jetzt wissen
wir nicht meinst du weißt du auch so
ohne mal zu probieren ja nein
maxi fakes sage ich ich habe die
originale stimmt das war so eindeutig
bei diesen ersten rostock sie da nicht
ganz zu machen und erst dann aber dann
auf einmal kickt diese nuss so rainer
maria woelki kraft mit diesem kran gp
haben den listen erstellt gekauft jetzt
42 sollte mit schubsen wir haben
leibnitz gegen feste war okay aber der
war so pixeln jeweils ein original oder
einen fake auf dem teller ich habe so
eine spezielle mit cruise schon
bis lage original tolkien wo mein gott
wie kann die kopiert haben hast du die
rede probieren und ja das macht die
anzug original besorgen da das original
macht es richtig kurios und den orio
fake gruft wenn du willst ja ok oh mein
gott wo man ihn war es sein 13 euro
das trio ich verwende meinen mantel okay
okay okay okay ich sage ich nehme auch
nicht mal muss das hier besorgen
das hier ist ja heute so salzig oder süß
salzig schmeckt das geruchlose der
kriege leute nachdem max floer weisen
erste runde kein punkt kommen hat steht
es jetzt immer noch unentschieden das
heißt wir machen genau zwei unten um den
sie el festzustellen und undicht
erkennen das salz nicht richtig haben
wir jemals einen original einfach drauf
okay das hier das ist das spiel lieber
noch ich sag mal dass intensivere erst
das originale also das was gegessen habe
und das original sein
ja und jetzt leute die finale und ich
kann jetzt nur noch mit den getrennten
gleichziehen macht kann sein
die noch helfen wenn du jetzt auch bei
dem kohle original umfeld gesagt hat ich
hab so richtig kein cola light control
das heißt ich muss das eigentlich
schaffen ich muss eigentlich klingt
eigentlich protokolle des fan tauschen
ja okay ich habe meinen stern gefällt
und was sagst du kannst du auch im namen
der kinder hat ich habe die nal in der
hand ich finde das hat ein zug rast
zitronen note ich sage auch das ist auch
genau das ist fake damit habe ich der
einzige fahrer der einzig wahre
süßigkeiten verkürzter m&m verkoster
trockenheit sucht die mensch der in
regen über heute mag sich der sieger des
heutigen tages max in dem schreiben
verlinkt sollte lieber sachen schnell
verlegen sie findet aber vorerst geht
heute irgendwann irgendwann die
süßigkeiten haben wir schreibt
kommentator 1